[Music]
scotts where the scots in phoenix
arizona hey scott what's up in your
world
oh all good things well i'm glad sir how
can we help today yeah
uh well my wife and i were wondering we
want to shut down
any access to our credit because we're
debt free and we don't want to apply for
credit
and we don't want anybody to apply for
credit under our names
and how do we go about doing that you
freeze
your credit and
it's usually a small fee 20 bucks or
something
and you can freeze it there are three
credit bureau reporting
agencies and you need to freeze it with
all of them
trw transunion and experian
and that's the three i have frozen all
of
ours and we froze all of our children's
when they were
children to my knowledge they have not
unfrozen them for any reason because
they don't borrow money either
anytime you want your credit checked it
cannot be checked
you would have to pay another fee to
unfreeze it temporarily let it be
checked and then freeze it again
all right no one no one can look at your
credit and your credit can not be sold
to anyone because these credit bureau
reports sell your name
that's where you get a lot of this crap
in the mail
they don't sell your details but they
you can buy
i can go to experian and i can buy uh
people that fit a certain uh demographic
outline
uh of income or credit type or whatever
and i can buy i can buy blocks of those
to market
to you if i want you're off of that if
you
if you freeze your credit because no one
can access it
um now it does not keep you
from having your identity stolen
let me give you an example okay
uh let's pretend that some doob
uh gets your social security number
through one of the nine million
different hacks that have happened out
there and people got
you know all of target's information all
of whoever's information they end up
somehow with your social security number
and they take your social security
number and they apply for a visa
at bank of america the big banks
when they're approving a credit card uh
application
only check the credit on two out of ten
apps
they automatically approve the other
eight
and so if your credit if they if you're
one of those eight and they don't even
check your credit
then the thief can open an account in
your name
and all of a sudden you've had it's an
identity theft situation you're not
liable for the debt because it's a
fraudulent transaction
but it's a hassle to get out of and
that's why we recommend zander insurance
identity theft and i carry that on
myself my kids and
all of my employees i furnish it as an
employee benefit
because of this kind of stuff that's out
there and so
these idiot banks will actually open an
account and loan people money without
even pulling the credit bureau report
because on average they come out
it works out for them but it's just they
it
doesn't work out for it it doesn't work
out for you
so in other words if they don't go to
you if they come to your frozen account
and check it
they'll go oh ding ding it's frozen this
must be fraudulent and they will reject
the application
so if if whoever the identity whoever
the lender is that someone's trying to
steal your identity with
checks your credit that that thief would
be denied
and so it does help with identity theft
but it does not prevent it
because sometimes they don't even bother
to check the bureau and that's what
you're getting into
so yeah you can freeze it and that's
what i did and you can get xander
insurance
identity theft protection and that's
what i did and the reason we have
endorsed
xander insurance's version all these
years is because the big thing about
identity theft
is not that you owe money it's that it
takes you 600
hours on average to clean up your
account after your identity's been
stolen
because you have to go talk to bank of
america and go no that wasn't me
oh sure you just don't want to pay your
bill no it wasn't me
oh we'll transfer you to the fraud
victim department and then i have to get
a police report
and then have to sign notarized
statements and i have to do all this
crap
to not pay a bill that i didn't even
take out was fraudulently taking out my
name
because you people are doofuses and
issued credit without even checking the
credit bureau report
it's like somehow i get the brunt of
that but that's what identity theft does
to you it steals your time
because you don't owe the money when
someone steals your identity you didn't
borrow the money it's fraudulent
transaction
you're not you're not liable for fraud
but but you have to go clean it all up
and xander
take the xander protection assigns a
counselor to you
and they go do all that work oh wow and
it gets done a lot more efficiently than
me calling
and arguing with some idiot on the phone
at citibank well also
by the way that's what you get on the
phone at citibank if i'm an hourly
employee it is going to cost me money
right i'm going to have to sit there and
take some time i can't just
well it costs me money because it takes
years off my life
and you only have a few of those left
man yeah i know i'm right at the end
here
i'm right at the end and so anything
that causes me to lose more hair
is valuable to me we are counting very
valuable
shut up john shut up john old person
jokes john i mean
really you are really this is you're
above that you really are
no matter maybe maybe you're not maybe
you're not
i mean i'm just i could be wrong but i
mean yeah because it just
you know talking to somebody on in a
cubicle in new york at citibank
or god help you in some other country
where they've outsourced it
or making a police report to an
overtaxed police department
oh yeah right they ain't got anything to
do you know they're not worried about
like real crime
i listen i got 700 opened up in my name
at citibank i need a police report
right and they're like oh we're kind of
busy right now
and we have real criminals out here no
that's a real criminal well it's 700
but i ain't i never thought of freezing
my kids accounts i'm gonna do that this
week
there you go it's a great idea there you
go